all right let's go through uh a few
different news stories from the last 24
hours today is the nra convention
national rifle association in houston
texas it is also texas the state
the site of the deadliest mass shooting
in a school since sandy hook a decade
ago
and donald trump is going to be speaking
at the nra convention greg abbott is
going to be speaking there ted cruz is
going to be speaking there and all of
them blame everything other than guns
for the mass shooting that took place
earlier this week that's what
republicans do
there has been increased pressure that i
mean listen there's been pressure that
the convention not even happened it's a
vile event by an organization whose goal
is just to sell guns their clients are
the gun manufacturers they are paid by
gun manufacturers to increase demand for
guns that's what they do but short of
the event being canceled
there's been pressure on people like
donald trump not to speak there but
donald trump plans to speak there and he
is doubling down posting to his
uh
you know his i guess it's a social media
platform truth social truth essential
yeah he posted quote
america needs real solutions and real
leadership in this moment
not politicians and partisanship
that's why i will keep my longtime
commitment to speak in texas at the nra
convention and deliver an important
address to america
in the meantime we will continue to pray
for the victims their families and for
our entire nation we are all in this
together
going on to say a horrible time for our
country
the idea that because we need solutions
it makes sense to speak at the nra the
nra is never going to have a solution to
school shootings or shootings in general
the nra wants more people to buy guns
one of the ways that you get people to
buy more guns is to make them believe
that it's really dangerous out there or
to actually allow it to be really
dangerous out there it's sort of the
same thing if people think they need a
gun they're going to go and buy a gun
and then if there's fewer shootings you
go and you say hey that's thanks to guns
go out and buy more guns either way
the nra's solution
is to buy more guns and the idea that
they are going to be an arbiter or a a
meeting point of any kind of actual
solutions is absurd it is insane
that what 96 hours after this shooting
in the same state the nra is gathering
to talk about how great guns are and how
access to them shouldn't be restricted
so trump will be speaking there it's
disgusting it's depraved it's absurd but
it's exactly what we would expect him to
do
we've talked often about the
mediterranean diet the mediterranean
diet one element is olive oil and many
olive oils are adulterated with fillers
other types of oils are made with oils
that are old or low quality
brightland is where you get the good
stuff brightland is a california-based
company offering authentic fresh olive
oils and vinegars made from local
harvests never over processed no fillers
or artificial preservatives because
brightland only works with small
california-based family-run farms that
don't use harmful chemicals they pay all
workers a living wage every bottle has a
label with the harvest date olives are
harvested early in the season pressed
within 90 minutes of harvest for the
highest quality oil possible brightland
sells an olive oil set called the duo
which i've been using at home it's
unbeatable one is called awake it's a
robust
oil for breads and soups the other is
called alive it's smoother great for
veggies and salads brightland ships to
you in recyclable bottles that protect
against uv light and in sustainable
packaging when you go to brightland.co
pacman you'll get 10 off the duo the
link is down below